joining me now is Ohio Senator JD Vance
Senator Vance I realize that both
Senators Brown and fetterman and I guess
he was doing this from his hospital room
have co-sponsored your legislation so
that's good but the people in this area
and also in Western Pennsylvania they
still feel abandoned so why hasn't the
president shown up
well I can't explain that Laura and and
frankly why hasn't his administration
shown up until Trump and other folks
effectively forced the administration to
start paying attention to this you know
there are two sides of this law of
course you want the government to do its
basic job you want the EPA and other
folks to actually be on the ground
responding to the crisis in real time
that took longer than it should have
though I'm happy to say that there's
some progress being made there you also
just want leaders to actually show up
and let people know that they care and
that's one of the ways in which the bide
Administration has been a totally
catastrophic failure they blamed the
Trump Administration on the one hand
which was completely nonsensical in
addition to being complete partisan
hackery and they refused to show up on
the other hand it's no wonder the folks
of East Palestine feel left behind I've
been fighting every single day to make
sure they get the support that they need
and that we actually respond to the
crisis but look the bite Administration
has by and large not going to help
so Biden did send out his press
secretary though uh Senator to answer
for his absence from the area watch this
I don't have any trips to preview for
you at this time this has been a
priority we have had a multi-agency
reaction to this an operation on the
ground making sure that the community
and Eddie's Palestine was getting what
they needed to get back on their feet
and to make them whole
so I went to Ukraine went to Poland did
the big speeches
can't show up in his own country but
Donald Trump did what did the Trump
visit mean to the people on the ground
well the first thing it meant is it
shown a light on what's going on in East
Palestinian like so many people felt
forgotten so the fact that you know
president Trump showed up actually
talked to the people just made them feel
like somebody was paying attention I
actually do think it actually physically
kicked the Biden Administration in the
proverbial teeth a little bit and got
them off their rear ends they needed to
pay attention to this area they needed
to send resources to this area I gotta
say they've been a lot better since
Trump came to town than they were
beforehand and I think the president
deserves a lot of credit for that
Chuck Schumer decided to try to Gaslight
the issue this week watch
it is so typical for people like Donald
Trump to do the bidding of special
interests cause harm to the American
people
that's what he did when he loosened
railroad regulations and then point the
finger at someone else when something
terrible happens that's just what he did
here
well what's the truth here their attempt
to blame Trump
look this really bothers me Laura
because it's a complete dereliction of
leadership look when you talk about
regulations this is an obvious point or
at least it should be you want to get
rid of regulations that don't promote
Public Safety but you want to make sure
that we actually are ensuring Public
Safety with the laws that we have there
is not a single regulation or
deregulatory thing that the Trump
Administration did that you can pin on
East Palestine in other words the
president I mean president Trump
deserves none of the blame his
administration did nothing that promoted
the disaster in East Palestine and this
effort to try to force blame on Trump
it's not just wrong on the facts it
distracts us from the job which is what
my legislation tries to do I mean
they're blaming Trump for inflation
they're trying to blame him for crying
myself someone trying to do and now this
it is preposterous Senator great to see
you and thank you for your leadership
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
telling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else